[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity now despite the explosive
horowitz findings that detailed massive
surveillance abuse and FISA fraud
against Carter page and the Trump
campaign the congenital liar
corrupt Adam Schiff is still showing no
remorse for perpetuating a years-long
hoax and spreading FISA lies take a look
Carter page says that the FBI spying
into his life ruined his good name
that's a quote he also says that he will
quote never completely have his name
restored do you feel any sympathy for
Carter page I have to say you know
Carter page came before committee and
four hours of his testimony denied
things that we knew were true later had
to admit them during his testimony it's
also hard to be sympathetic when you
have someone who has admitted to being
an advisor to the Kremlin but that was
also informing the CIA yes yes which we
didn't know about incredible really that
should shock the conscience
Carter page was smeared for years
accused of being a traitor all based on
lies innuendo and a phony dossier and
Adam Schiff doesn't have the guts to
even admit he was wrong and show a
little remorse and this is the same liar
by the way who wrote the now debunked
FISA memo and was given the green light
to run the Democrats impeachment
witch-hunt he's corrupt to the core it's
undeniable now the good news is the
boomerang of Justice is in full swing
because not only is John doar honing in
on the actions of ex CIA director John
Brennan but according to a new report in
The New York Times doram got into a
quote sharp dispute over a draft
footnote in the Horowitz report that
implied Durham agreed with all of the I
G's conclusions including political bias
now the footnote was not included in the
final report suggesting Durham is
uncovering convincing evidence refuting
horowitz's conclusions from Comey -
clapper - Brennan
some of America's most powerful
bureaucrats abuse their power to try and
undo the results of a presidential
election the time for accountability is
now joining me now for reaction is
author of the book power grab Fox News
contributor
jason chaffetz along with author of the
great book witch hunt Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett and Fox News
contributor and investigative reporter
John Solomon who's reporting I've come
to rely on extensively thanks guys all
for joining us Greg I'll go to you first
this thing with quarter-page Greg is an
abomination and it's not hyperbole we
have a Naval Academy graduate who has
never been charged with any crime who is
actually doing work now we know for an
intelligence agency thought to be the
CIA to nail Russians working in this
country to hurt this country the FBI the
FBI then targets this guy and
manipulates an email to suggest that his
contacts with those said Russians were
on behalf of some nefarious treasonous
act I mean this is one of the most
disgusting episodes of malfeasance I've
ever seen in law enforcement and James
Comey knew it because when the first
story started to appear late summer of
2016
identifying Carter page page sends a
letter to call me saying it's not true
I've been helping the CIA I'd be happy
to sit down and talk with you Comey
ignored the letter and sought a FISA
warrant but Adam Schiff is one of the
first people to publicly accuse Carter
page of being a Russian spy before the
FISA warrant situation and you just
played a clip of shift accusing Carter
page of lying in front of the
intelligence committee
completely untrue the testimony was
November 2nd 2017 I've read it a dozen
times whole portions of it are repeated
in my book
Carter page told the truth if it were
otherwise he would have been accused of
and prosecuted for perjury no Adam
Schiff continues to lie and if you I
invite people to actually read the
transcript it's online Carter page not
only tells the truth but Adam Schiff
makes an absolute fool of himself
trying on cross-examination to get
Carter page to admit that merely shaking
the hand of a criminal and official and
saying hello is somehow the hobgoblin of
a grand conspiracy to commit a
treasonous act and steal the 2000
election 2016 election Adam Schiff in
his contort
and twisted mind may still believe it
and it's ludicrous
no it's sustained in our country too
disgusting episode John I'll go to you
your reporting has been just spectacular
I have relied on it extensively and it's
good to see now even some in the media
who had tried to tarnish your reputation
are now starting to come around realize
you were right the whole time I know
you've got some yeah they are stubborn
things I know you've got some
information on call me but it's obvious
now that Comey lied we I saw a footnote
this weekend footnote 323 that's right
call me had told President Trump in this
January 7 2017 meeting we weren't really
investigating the dossier salacious and
unverified footnote tweet 323 says they
were not only investigating it they were
sending FBI agents overseas to
investigate steel sources this guy I
mean it really his reputation has got to
be finished it is and some of the allies
that he's told to Congress or
misstatements are are really serious
issues for instance he says at one point
I didn't know that the Carter page had
been opened up on in the spring of 2016
that was one of the revelations in the
the IG report and in fact there's notes
from Pete stroke showing he was in a
meeting with James Coleman they talked
about it same thing about Bruce or he
didn't know about Bruce or the backdoor
way they were getting Steele's
information and after Steel's fired
their strokes notes they're saying he
was in a meeting we briefed him hunt
Bruce or James Comey has an issue now
and I think as Durham advances this
criminal investigation there's a high
probability they're gonna look at him
for false statements you know that's
fascinating because that whole
information laundering scheme they're
running with Bruce or again another
thing just another lie in the just
bevy of Comey lies he's told congressman
Chaffetz one of the things that's
bothered me is the media malfeasance and
this we said joke on Sean he studies
media for a living but they keep
suggesting that the IG report says
there's no political bias that is not
what the report said matter of fact
Horowitz's own words in front of the
Senate committee were clear although I
didn't find a document saying yes we
opened up on Trump because we hate him
and he's politically biased he said it
was one of two things it was either
gross negligence or political bias just
goes to show you how the media will take
anything and spin it for the Democrats
narrative and also what the Inspector
General said is that he did not look at
it he could not demonstrate defended
one way or the other if any bias was
injected into itself in the actual FISA
applications what he said is he couldn't
find mr. pre step that he had documented
any sort of bias he was the senior most
person that started this this operation
but that's like not even a page of a
four hundred and fifty page IG report if
anybody thinks they were exonerated or
cleared
are you kidding me I mean Comey takes it
in the shorts for the fifth time in over
a thousand pages now documented from the
inspector general so good luck without
mr. Comey I want to get a quick answer
from the three of you on this because
I'm genuinely curious about how much
trouble do you think go with you Craig
first John Brennan is in and the reason
I ask it is one point or in this morn
testimony of Lisa page
she tells congressman Mark Meadows under
oath that she would be genuinely stunned
if the CIA was getting information from
Steele in other words it seems like
Brett and may have been I'm not giving
the FBI a pass believe me if Comey lied
throughout this whole thing but it seems
at some point that if there was a puppet
master of this from the Intel side it
may have been John Brennan by I call
Brennan the instigator in my book he
created before there was a steel dossier
an interagency task force that was the
original foundation you know this John
was the foundation for the Trump Russia
collusion hoax and so I think Brennan
has a lot to answer for and I think
Durham may be looking at false
statements insofar as Brennan is
concerned
John Gregg has it exactly right I think
that interagency task force is going to
be one of the places that get cracked
open by Durham we're gonna learn a lot
also on the issue of bias the biggest
bias that was ever injected this
investigation was the steel dossier he
admitted he was desperate to defeat
Trump and the FBI used that to go to the
FISA Court biases all over this
investigation anyone who says it isn't
is blind to it and Weissman knew it
congressman how much trouble you think
John Brennan is in in this he's in a lot
of trouble I agree with the other two
but I would also say Dan follow the
money there are millions of dollars that
flowed from the Democrats overseas and
Durham is able to go look at that
something Horowitz couldn't look at that
is going to tell a lot about the the the
travesty that was done here Jason Greg
John thanks guys you're great really
appreciate it thanks a lot